I think he had to go for it  also we belong the clock  I mean okay this is  this is some incredible and the Knight  heads to A4 hitting the pawn on B2 so  white was not in time to get his King to  HD covering 35 now 94 9879 B5 now he's  just losing  unbelievable strategic Master Class by  the world champion  Bishop can't try to defend this but then  you lose the pawn and he keeps waiting  but it's bound to fail  foreign  s for for the French  and that's it and Sovereign  wow I mean this is this was true art  what we have witnessed really I mean I  suggested the move but Bishop E2 was  such a turnaround no from a completely  safe actually probably winning end game  after C4